is another exciting edition of market
takes i am dion rabowen a reporter at
the wall street journal and we are
diving all the way into i don't know the
the briefest speech the most you know
straight to the point speech i think
i've seen fed chairman jerome powell
give we are talking about his speech
today at jackson hole at the
jacksonville symposium man eight minutes
my man cut to the bone
uh he was right straight to the point we
were gonna dig into everything he said
and talk all about it so we're talking
about not only what he said but we're
going to talk about how the market
reacted the market reaction we've seen
uh since the speech came out and since
he delivered it since he since he
finished it we're going to talk about
the environment that we had coming into
that speech uh what the data was telling
us before the chairman really took the
podium and spoke as well as how this
changes things what the outlook is going
forward now that we've heard from fed
chair jerome powell and why this jackson
hole speech is so important i'm also
going to tell you guys what's coming
next so we're going to dive into all of
that right now look
the big message today from fed chair
powell was
no pivot we are not pivoting i said what
i said
uh and i meant it look he's saying we
are not going to stop raising rates
until the job is done as we had seen
over the past couple months months
markets had been pricing in a fed
reversal a fed pivot if you want to call
it basically expecting that the fed was
going to hike rates through this year
and then kind of take a pause going into
next year and then next year into the
summer start to cut rates back down uh
to help boost the economy fed chairman
jerome powell coming out today and
saying in no uncertain terms that is not
the plan that's not what we expect to do
and and you really got a very strong and
like i said a a a dose of brevity from
the chairman today
the chairman jerome powell said look
we must keep at it until the job is done
that's a direct quote
he referenced paul volcker the the fed
chairman who's known for whipping
inflation in the 1980s you know raising
rates all the way up to around 20
percent to get inflation back down uh
the fed chairman who's known for causing
a a painful recession in the 1980s and
who really was not popular at the time
that it happened fed chairman jerome
powell today referencing him three
separate times he said a restrictive
policy stance could be appropriate for
quote some time meaning that hey you
know what you guys who are expecting us
to just raise rates and then cut them
back down again that's not happening
that's not what we got going right now
um
i i think it's really important to sort
of look at this from the context of
different markets and how they responded
to that we're going to get into it i
want to read a quote really quickly uh
from brian coulton he is the chief
economist at fitch ratings uh and he he
said something that i thought was really
interesting he said quote this was a
clear pushback on market expectations of
a pivot from the fed in 2023
after being surprised by the intensity
and duration of inflation pressures over
the last 12 months the fed is now
clearly determined to make sure high
inflation does not become embedded look
this is what the fed has been saying
this is what powell has been saying
markets really weren't listening at
least the stock market wasn't listening
uh it seems like if you're looking at
the market today and you're seeing all
that red the market clearly was
listening um
last thing that brian coulton said was
the fed is clearly not going to be
swayed by volatility in gasoline prices
the big reason we've seen a lot of the
step down in not just inflation but
inflation expectations has been the
decline we've seen in gasoline prices
we've seen gas prices decline for
about 70 days so far going on three
months where gasoline prices just
steadily declined declined to climb even
as the price of oil has been a little
bit more volatile the price of gasoline
at the pump has been declining that has
been changing consumer expectations of
inflation and overall consumer
expectations um this jackson hole speech
was big not just because it set the tone
or set the tempo on that pivot this is
the fed's one chance to really
communicate with folks from around the
globe central bankers from around the
world gather at jackson hole wyoming
discuss monetary policy the theme of
this year's event was all about the the
limits for policy and and what can be
done on the economy and fed chair jerome
powell really very clearly drew a line
in the sand said listen
we're not backing off we are not going
to stop until the job is done and and
this was a
an important place to lake that to make
that message and to make sure it was
received
eight minutes less than nine minutes the
chairman spoke
and got straight to the point and said
and reiterated a number of times the
point that he was making which is that
the fed is not going to stop until
inflation is under control and that
could be in 2023 it might not be till
2024. he said the fed is not going to
take their foot off the break i guess is
how you could look at this so look we
when we go into wsj.com we check the
market data you were seeing if you're
looking at the stock market you were
just seeing stocks plummeting right now
you've got the dow down almost two
percent uh the nasdaq down 2.7 the s p
500 down more than two percent about two
point two percent and and that's all
been since the fed chairman stopped
talking actually when the the speech
with text was first released right
before he started talking at 10 am you
saw the market sell off then you saw the
market actually come back while he was
speaking as folks kind of said um maybe
this isn't so bad let's buy buy buy and
you saw each of those indexes the s p
the nasdaq the dow all get back to about
even or zero on the day and then since
then there's just been a massive
sell-off and we're seeing now the nasdaq
down almost three percent
bond yields a much less dramatic
reaction because the bond market really
had been listening to these fed speakers
had been looking through some of the
documents that have been released and
the bond market had sort of been seeing
okay
we don't think this pivot is really
going to come if you've been watching
bonds over the past couple of weeks the
past three weeks really since the fed's
last meeting you had seen a significant
pickup in bond prices bond yields kind
of picking back up or sorry a turn down
in bond prices bond yields picking back
up moving higher and and you saw that
today now the bond market is saying this
was about what we expected we didn't
think the fed was going to be done
we thought that they were going to keep
raising rates and keep rates high i
think that's really the big thing here
is even if the fed's done raising rates
next year they're going to keep them
there up around that four percent level
potentially maybe even higher than that
as we've heard some fed officials say
four percent is significantly more
restrictive policy that's tighter policy
from the monetary side
than we have seen in a generation you
have to go back before the 2008
financial crisis to get to a time when
u.s interest rates were that high and
they haven't stayed that high again if
you remember back to 2018 the fed tried
to raise rates fed chairman jerome
powell said you know we don't think
rates are at neutral yet we've got a
long ways to go when the fed was at 2.25
percent which is right about where we
are now by the way uh the fed chairman
said we don't think we're anywhere close
to neutral we don't think we're eating
we're close to done we've got we've got
a lot more to do
the next month they raised rates again
that was the last increase that you saw
they reversed course by the end of the
year start of 2019 they started cutting
rates and that's what the market
expected to see again fed chair jerome
powell saying nah not this time
and the bond market seems to have have
priced that in so you're not seeing a
big move from bonds right now we look at
fed fund futures you're not seeing a big
move there either you're seeing a slight
tweak in expectations for a rate of a 75
basis point hike uh at the september
meeting rather than a 50 point hike
which had been pre factored in about a
week or two ago
so over the course of a week you're
seeing a move more towards 75 basis
points or three times the normal rate
versus 50 basis points or two times the
normal rate
and that's that change has happened over
the past week or so but today not a huge
move on fed fund futures not a huge move
in the bond markets you are seeing a bit
of a tightening uh from the yield curve
you're seeing 30-year rates those
long-term bond yields coming down a
little bit more than those short-term
yields
and that's just a little bit more of the
market saying
oh we're uneasy we think this might be a
little recessionary we think the fed
might raise rates a little too far cause
a recession but overall right now the
market the bond market at least is
saying we think that jerome powell and
the federal reserve have things in good
control and we are not that worried uh
you saw commodities oil prices jump gold
jump during the speech and then just
like most other markets sold that off
later so we're seeing commodities
overall down right now
just like we're seeing a lot of the
overall market down
uh commodities prices let me check here
on wsj.com we're seeing crude oil down
just a little bit brent crude down a
little bit more than uswti
gold is selling off silver is selling
off
but natural gas is up about a percentage
natural gas looking unstoppable right
now reached record highs recently
looking like it's going towards around
ten dollars
for on the futures market and and that's
that's something that i think folks
ought to keep an eye on because that's
gonna impact utility costs but anyway
not to get lost we were sticking with
the fed and and the the market reaction
overall today right now most things on
the downward slide moving lower the
dollar actually got a bump and i think
what's really interesting is if you look
at the wsj dollar index versus the
overall usdxy dollar index you're seeing
a significant difference in terms of uh
after fed chair powell's comments the
wsj dollar index went up the overall u.s
dollar index went down and the big
difference there is the wsj dollar index
measures dozens of currencies versus the
dollar the overall usdxy index measured
versus just six currencies the biggest
one being the euro euro got a big bump
today from some ecb policymakers over at
the european central bank saying that
they were prepared to do even more to
raise rates by maybe 75 basis points
which would be really kind of historic
for that central bank which has been
incredibly dovish aka kept policy rates
low kept interest rates low and even
negative
for quite some time so the takeaway the
market was a bit unsure powell came out
he was strong today he said very clearly
we are not pivoting we are not turning
around and cutting rates next year you
guys better be prepared for us to do
this for the long term
bond market had kind of factored that in
you're seeing a little bit of price
movement there but the stock market
clearly had not and a lot of that
bullishness that had been factored in to
market since you know that june 16th low
that we had seen in the stock market and
we've kind of taken off from there that
looks to be fading out of the stock
market right now as investors factor in
a tighter uh a more
you know a fed that's more committed to
keeping rates high um
listen
we we had seen this happen this
difference in markets uh whether it's
the dollar whether it's bonds whether
it's stocks the dollar rising higher
lately is something to definitely keep
an eye on because that could help keep
inflation uh out that could help keep a
lid on inflation keep inflation down
we'd seen that trend reversing as folks
the market got more bullish and that was
one thing we did we did a a video
dispatch or a story here on youtube
about a week ago about how that weak
dollar could undermine sort of this uh
soft landing thesis that the market had
priced in well it looks like we may not
get that and so if this if the dollar
remains strong
if the dollar continues to hold up here
that could be another thing that helps
keep inflation down and that could
overall be good for the economy though
it be could be another factor weighing
on the stock market definitely keep that
in mind the data we got earlier this
morning also important because it tells
us a lot about where powell's head was
and what the fed is thinking consumer
confidence has been consistently
rebounding a lot of that has to do with
the price of oil and the price of gas
coming down at the pump we saw continued
improvement from the consumer confidence
index from university of michigan came
out early this morning again even higher
than earlier this month since hitting
that low in june
we've seen consumer confidence continue
to pick up since hitting that 50 mark
and that really has coincide right along
with the decline in gas prices so as gas
prices fall uh inflation expectations
have fallen and consumer confidence
expectations have continued to rise and
go up folks feeling a lot better about
their economic situation as those gas
prices continue to come down uh retail
sales remember that was up just ever so
slightly up ten percent year over year
but month over month about flat but up
just ever so slightly
that was a strong number and remember we
saw that strong jobs report for july
at the beginning of august next week we
will be right here talking to you about
the jobs numbers those strong jobs
numbers though starting to worry the fed
you saw atlanta fed chair atlanta fed
president rafael bostic this morning
kind of come out and say uh we're we're
not loving these uh these strong jobs
numbers that we've seen which is an
interesting thing to say from a policy
maker so keep your eye on that if the
fed starts to talk more about how the
jobs numbers are too strong that could
be something that really moves the
market as well a strong jobs report next
week could actually move the market
lower if it looks like that means the
fed has to do more work
so taking a step back we are rolling
towards the end of market takes here and
i want to thank you so much for being
with us
again i'm dionne robone reporter with
the wall street journal let's step back
and and just talk about the takeaways
fed chair jerome powell strong resolute
banging the table pounding the table we
are not done we are not pivoting we are
going to stay strong i'm going to be
like paul volcker and whip inflation
that's what he said today and the market
reacted powell is not on board with the
fed pivot and that's why we're seeing
stocks decline because higher interest
rates make it more expensive for
companies to borrow makes it harder for
them to grow and expand and more
expensive and and again these companies
these high-flying tech companies their
future cash flows their future profits
are discounted when interest rates are
higher
this was a bit at odds with the fed rent
with the minutes from the fed's last
meeting that were released last week but
you know what if you've listened to fed
speakers over the past couple weeks they
have been singing the same tune they're
saying we are not done we are not
reversing course and fed chair jerome
powell today came out and said that very
strongly so what comes next we get more
data the fedshare pal also said we are
going to be data dependent we're not
locking anything in 75 50. you know no
matter how many
we're not gonna say right away today
we're going to do this in september and
then we're going to do this going
forward he says we're going to look at
the data because they're i think very
wary right now of getting another
surprise high inflation report
of being surprised with another
continued growth in the jobs market so
be sure next week that you are right
here with us on market takes we are
going to be opening up and diving into
the jobs report
that we get
at the beginning of september for august
so we'll be talking about that also the
cpi report is going to be big
and of course next week we get the
case-shiller home prices report we get
another report on consumer confidence
and the jolts jobs report that's going
to be big
so be sure to make sure you're watching
that data and be sure you're with us
here on market takes next week as we
dive into that jobs report look i would
be remiss if i did not take this
opportunity to say a fond farewell and a
salute to kansas city fed president
esther george she's retiring at the end
of this year she has been very
entertaining for those of us who watch
the fed she has been a strong dissenter
against policy when everybody else in
the fed was on board with cutting rates
with more quantitative easing with
providing more support for the economy
esther george said no it didn't really
do much they went ahead and did it
anyway but she has been a very
interesting person to watch a strong
voice for tighter monetary policy for
the hawks out there on the fed and for
you know for a for years of service this
will be her last
jackson hole
symposium as president of the kansas
city fed so i just wanted to send a
salute and a strong goodbye to esther
george
shout out to her and the rest of the
kansas city fed team out there very
interesting to see who's going to be the
next president that comes in there
that's going to do it for us here on
market takes thank you for being with us
i know you could have been anywhere in
the world but you were here with me and
i want to say i appreciate you for that
we will be here next friday when the
jobs report is released please come back
and join us then i'm dianne rabone and i
hope to see you right back here on
market takes